I love cook TV and I'm a c-span fans
[Music]
thank you for coming welcome to Nellie's
sports bar my name is Doug Stan's and
Nellie's is actually named after my
great-grandmother so there's a piece of
history for you they're speaking a
history we have Jim Downs the expert in
history and his team historian I've
known Jim Jimmy downs for almost 20
years
so we met when we were about 10 we met
in Rehoboth Beach and he's become a very
good true friend and also lastly mom who
is a professor at University of Richmond
also a good friend and they're going to
talk tonight about Jim's new book stand
by Leeds so without further ado welcome
and thank you thank you so I want to
thank Doug you know the wonderful people
at Nellie's for making this opportunity
happen
and I'm also excited about being a
conversation with Jim DeMint 2005 at a
gym and in 2005 all these social apps
weren't there and quite the way that we
understand them today so it was an
intellectual interaction that we had at
the gym and it was by anomalous machines
in case any of you are thinking about it
so Jim to work is fundamentally
committed to questions of social justice
as well as participation democratic
systems as - as well and it's exciting
to have an opportunity to talk about
this particular book which is stamp on a
forgotten history of gay liberation and
part of that history has been included
by the AIDS crisis so anything that
happened before is really part of an
archive the grief you have had an
opportunity that actually investigated
and that's part of why this book is so
important to me and my various readings
of it as well as the framing concedes of
the book for those of you who haven't
read the book and I'm assuming that most
of you haven't and those of you who have
read the book could you raise your hand
awesome
I'm actually mildly surprised because it
just came out so you have fans Jim so
the book tries to understand for
formative stages that led to the
creation of gay liberation movements in
the 70s and that has to do with one
something that seems fundamentally
antithetical to our current political
moment
which is how queers got together along
the lines of religious identity to form
community and safeguards that would
allow them to thrive in ways that they
otherwise wouldn't have second the
importance of book stores as well as
newspapers and connecting people before
the internet age in a way that kept them
close and lively and interested in
politics in a way that right now because
of the diffusion of information we
sometimes ignore and that's part of our
political problem right now
third was the question of the car school
system and how was it particularly that
during this particular epoch we really
have vast discrimination in terms of gay
prisoners entrapment plots by police in
various parts think of DC in the 70s I
know that none of you were born though
but if you might imagine you can think
through how possibilities for getting
together and engaging for sex for
commerce for love for the positive
winners are namely
and the culture that fundamentally
denied the right to be together is one
time and the fourth component which I'd
actually like to focus on if I have an
opportunity to do so has to do with the
emergence of the seventies what came to
be known as the gay clone so that gate
close been superseded by a lot of
initiatives that attempt to mark gay
marriage as a type of equality that may
not have been the same for those of us
invested in cross intersectional
politics in the 70s which included
people at color transgender communities
and the possibilities result making
outside the strictures of state
protections so part of the conversation
that I want to have with him is about a
story that he begins with that frames
his important book and that has to do
with a 1973 fire that happened in New
Orleans in one of the districts that I'm
sure we're all familiar with because we
all go to New Orleans like his face to
go to Las Vegas to either forget or
remember past love sort of future
possibilities and that story has been
fundamentally alighted and erased from
the historical record in in part that
informative methodology that is how to
approach an optical study and that is
queerness LGBTQ communities in the 70s
and I was wondering before we delve into
those form those four frames that I've
just given you from the church to
bookstores to the carceral system to the
macho clone how that began your
investigation okay so like major
shout-out to Nellie's first of all for
hosting us here tonight because you know
the reality of it is the reality of it
is is that for gay people a bar like
this is also a place for people to come
together it's not only to come together
to socialize it's not only to come
together a party but throughout the
1970s and even to the present parties
and community happened in bars like this
so tonight what you're going to hear is
a discussion with lies and meat but
you're gonna also hear the party that's
happening here in LA because that's what
it means to be queer that's what it
means to be gay that's what it means to
occupy its face like this so I just want
to say that we're welcoming you c-span
into our community we're welcoming you
into the way in which things have been
done within gay communities for many
decades so basically I'm going to talk
to you initially about how I got started
with the book and that's what was kind
of sort of punted too so there are many
books about gay history out there lots
lots of books about how in the
post-world War two ERA we started to
find some semblance of gay people
fighting for rights creating their own
communities and developing a sense of
self and what's happened over time is
that we have created the story that
decade after decade from World War two
to 1969 with the infamous Stonewall
Rebellion during the 1970s through the
1980s through the 1990s we as a people
have mobilized and we have succeeded it
is a historian I realized that's not
that what happened in the 1970s is often
not talked about it's often overshadowed
and the question is what has
overshadowed that and the answer to that
is the outbreak of hiv/aids and so many
of you know the ways in which hiv/aids
has devastated the lives of countless
Americans and people across the world
but what people haven't realized is the
extent to which the HIV epidemic
actually retold the history of the 1970s
the 1970s was this incredibly vibrant
diverse moment in American history it
gave way to an explosion of churches it
gave way to an explosion of newspapers
long before there were apps long before
there was scruffed long before there was
Grindr gay men needed to communicate and
they turned to newspapers yet the
history of this has been overshadowed
because doctors policymakers public
health officials we're looking for an
explanation for why HIV spread and what
they said was the 1970s was a period of
unfettered sex that there were gay guys
and orgies that there were gay guys in
bars that there are gay guys just having
sex and my question as a historian was
how much of that is true and how much of
that has been used to rationalize the
spread of HIV where the 70s in fact this
period about just sex or have we defined
that era as about just sex in order to
explain the epidemic and my argument is
that we have diluted the history of the
1970s as a way to tell the origin
narrative of HIV and that as a result so
many key points in the history of the
1970s has remained untold
fact that there was this extensive quite
exhaustive religious Network the fact
that there was a print culture the fact
that gay men were thinking about
different types of bodies from very FEM
guys to bears to what we came to know as
the clone but all of that history all
that vibrance all of that nuance all of
that detail became shortened became
reduced to a story about explaining HIV
so that's what basically started the
history from my book that's what started
we need to sort of ask questions about
the 1970s and that's what led me to
uncovering the quite horrific and
poignant story of the upstairs lounge
lounge because it functions as a kind of
method in your book so if method refers
to the tools by which we apprehend up in
the plots at the study those methods
have a lot to say about historians fall
historical amnesia so how do those
methods about that New Orleans fire in
1973 informed the rest of the book and
become the framing
object of every study great so before I
get to this question let me just let me
just give a quick history of the
upstairs lounge fire because most people
don't know about the upstairs on fire
and the history of the upstairs lounge
fire is really significant and why I was
so excited to be here tonight at
Nellie's for this for this event was
because as I mentioned earlier bars have
been the site where gay people came
together and in the early 1970s many gay
people began to organize church groups
of religious organizations and other
institutions but were left out of
mainstream religious institutions so
they had to create their own and what
they did is they used to occupy just
like this tonight it's kind of evocative
the second floor of bars they would take
over a second floor they would take over
a room and they would organize the
religious service so in New Orleans On
June 21st 1973 a bunch of gay guys came
in to a bar in the early afternoon they
had a beer blast they heard about the
news of the Stonewall uprising four
years ago in New York City and I want to
just pause for a second how did gay men
learn about Stonewall in New Orleans the
straight press didn't talk about it
the news media didn't talk about it but
the gay press talked about it so gay
newspapers carried the story from New
York to a place like New Orleans and a
bunch of gay men gathered on June 24th
1973 to celebrate the fourth anniversary
of Stonewall but after the beer bust
ended around 7 o'clock everybody left
everybody went home people hooked up it
was a big party members of the
Metropolitan Community Church rented the
second room floor of the bar and they
gathered around the white piano David
Mary who is I think that's his name I'm
forgetting
he crossed the street from the Holiday
Inn where he worked playing the piano he
start playing Church and liturgical
songs they began singing a song united
we stand divided we fall if our back
should ever be up against the wall
we'll be together and someone knocked on
the door to get into the gay bar in the
1970s gay bars didn't have open windows
like this they weren't open to the
public no one from the street could walk
in so you had to buzz this the buzzer
and the bartender opened up a hatch like
a Prohibition speakeasy and he said no
no no we didn't ask for a cab you're not
allowed to come in we're fine and then
he heard a noise and someone and we
still don't know now 40 years later took
a firebomb and threw it on the second
floor of the church which was the bar
converted into a church and these men
were locked into a room and the way that
we could be locked into this room except
in New Orleans there were bars over the
windows and so the men were unable to
get out from the front windows a few of
the younger guys the the thinner guys
were able to miraculously squeeze their
bodies through the bars of the window
and many tried to escape through a back
entrance but the smoke filled the room
the electricity went out and over 32
people died in this fire it is the
largest massacre of gay people in US
history
and it hasn't been told when I
discovered evidence of this fire in the
newspapers in Philadelphia as I was
going through the gay community center
records I realized that the outbreak of
hiv/aids which was a major genocide
overshadowed this and I realized that
the history of this violence committed
against gay people has not been told now
I want to say to you history often feels
like something that's isolated from the
past history feels like something that
doesn't relate to our lives but I'm not
going to say to you that history repeats
itself
but I want to end by just telling you
the story of Reverend Larson Reverend
Larson was the person who led this
congregation in prayer he was the person
who ran the MCC Church and when he tried
to escape out of the window of the
upstairs lounge
he pushed an air-conditioner out the
window and when he pushed the
air-conditioner out the window an
air-conditioner from the floor above him
fell on him and it killed him and when
that air-conditioner killed him his body
was then lodged and stuck in the window
his body was left for over a day in the
window the New Orleans papers reported
this the major press showed images of
his body lodged in the window not
removed by the fire department not
removed from the police and when I saw
that story
I thought about Ferguson when I saw that
story
I thought about Michael Brown when I saw
that story I thought about black lives
matter and I thought about the fact that
when you think what mobilized what
mobilized black lives matter was the
idea that Michaels Brown's body was left
on the street and in a very similar way
Reverend Larson's body was left in a
window and just like Michaels Brown's
body mobilized black lives matter
Reverend Larsen's body mobilized gay
people throughout the country in order
to fight for recognition relegated to
his own
by virtue of the fact that by the time
the CDC reports on the first in the
money prices for AIDS and that was 1981
we begin to lose our historical
connection to our foremothers our
forefathers and those communities that
actually kept a type of trajectory alive
for us to understand artistry one of the
things that hiv/aids did after 1981 is
relegate us to a moment of historical
amnesia so when we think of all these
panegyrics about the Reagan's and most
recently about Nancy Reagan passing away
we tend to whitewash versions of history
that relegated us to a type of
non-existence that is commensurate with
a type of social body that makes no
relationship to the state meaningful
that is that has absolutely no rights
much like what you've mentioned right
now the black lives matter which has now
been instantiated as the brown lives
matter after the attacks by Trump on the
country's largest minority which happens
to be the to those over 55 million so
part of that quest of historians such as
yourself as too thin fado knew how to
reframe the generative moments that
allow us to think through history in
ways that are meaningful and bring us
closer to democratic practice that were
used to and to ask questions with far
more nuance than were used to it so how
does that story of historical amnesia
bring us closer to a type of democratic
practice that is meaningful well I mean
I think the first thing is that when you
think about this question of historical
amnesia you have to remember that most
gay people don't understand or think
about their history as significant and
one of the things is that if you were to
ask most gay people what is their
history they would try to trace that to
where was the origin for a marriage
equality where is the origin for
anti-discrimination laws where is the
origin for anti sodomy laws and what I'm
trying to sort of say is that in the
1970s a gay people were interested in
understanding their history not as a
vehicle or a tool to fight with the
government not as a vehicle or tool as a
way to show that they're legitimate but
as a vehicle or a tool to bring people
together as a community as a vehicle
tool to show that we as a people have a
significant history that connects us and
that brings us together that allows us
to stand together and it's not
necessarily just being mobilized to
fight whatever injustice that's against
us if you open up a 19th like if you
open up a 1970s newspaper you're gonna
find these guys are reading this like
completely arcane [ __ ] about the 19th
century they're reading stuff like
aiming Lowell who is like 19th century
borderline average writer from the
period right and they're reading these
two page exerts on her because they want
to know about queer people from the past
they wouldn't know about lesbians they
want to know about their history they're
not just trying to write their history
because they need to prove to people on
Capitol Hill that they're valid they're
not trying to write their history to
prove to people that they're legible
they're trying to find their history
because they want to connect with each
other and they want to also connect and
create a community and if you think
about it
that's also that's why American history
developed in the 1950s people if you
went to university is that I want to
study of American issue and I was like
saying you want to study cartoons
because people in the Academy people in
university thought that American history
was [ __ ] real history was European
history real history was classical
history American history was its country
cousin yet we created a narrative about
American history the Tea Party has
created a narrative about American
history the Republicans have created a
narrative about American history Hillary
Clinton Bernie Sanders have created a
narrative about history in order to
situate themselves and gay people have
always created a narrative about history
to situate themselves and that narrative
has been lost today in creation of a
sort of Grindr profile that says girl on
timeless this is like I just showed up I
woke up like this and the reality of it
is is you didn't wake up like this you
come out of a historical context you
come out of a historical moment you come
out of a period that allowed you to show
up like this conversation to have about
not having four fathers or mothers and
the story of transgender activists of
multiple colors and identities
that happen so when we talk today about
questions of history it actually reminds
me a very poignant chapter in your book
about what you call the macho clone
sorry we've inherited a version
antiseptic queerness that fundamentally
a single issue driven and that has to do
with marriage equality who gets left out
of those conversations when we focus on
one version of respectability and negate
the gray foundations that have become
undone by virtue of the AIDS crisis in
other words where we have templates
before of understanding polyamorous
relationships queer love various
manifestations and we're absolutely
connected and you've mentioned this many
times
apps those apps leave a fundamental
loneliness that adheres to being in the
whole world we're never alone we could
have someone all the time
but what makes us meaningful in relation
to human connections which is what's so
absolutely beautiful about that
particular tractor about the macho clone
and you talk a little bit about who gets
left out of that particular history
where I go to sell one rights as a
structuring principle of identity refers
sure I mean I would say this like for
most for most gay men they wake up and
they go to the gym and they have a
particular idea of what their body type
is going to be and they think it's
something that they just invented in
their mind I'm going to be I'm going to
be a gym boy or I'm gonna be a bear or
I'm gonna be a twink and it's like you
think you've invented this identity
yourself but in the 1970s what you begin
to see is that there are many forms of
being queer and many form of being many
forms of being gay and newspapers and
magazines showed super FEM guys super
butch guys guys that were in drogyn as'
and then what happened was at a certain
moment by the late 1970s white men began
to push out men of color they began to
push out women
and they began to emphasize that the
only way of being gay was to have really
big pecs a flat stomach a crew cut hair
jeans boots right a leather jacket
aviator sunglasses and that's what it
meant to be gay and if you didn't follow
that archetype then you weren't gay and
part of it was a way in which they
racialized
what it meant to be gay that is to say
that many people believed that being gay
then meant being white but in actuality
if you go back to the Stonewall
Rebellion in the late 1960s if you go
back to the early 1970s gay people
you're here today this bar exists today
because of the black civil rights
movement it exists because of the
women's liberation movement because gay
activists learned from black activists
they learned from the Black Power
movement they learn from feminists they
took those ideas in order to make queer
issues visible but by the late 1970s all
that was a race in favor of some hunky
beefy sexy quite seductive and appealing
guy but that completely undermined the
history of the origins of gay liberation
so on that note what we're going to do
now is we're just going to open this up
to questions from the audience and since
we have our c-span audience who's
watching at home and we hope that you
use a microphone to ask a question we do
that I just want to follow up because
that's a very important observation you
just made which is that the sort of
musculature type that developed at a
particular moment in history was a type
of protection
against AIDS that absolutely negated
other body's ability to exist within the
body politic versus what I believe
probably representing so I'm happy to
share the microphone with anybody who
might from the audience we're dying to
hear from you we would love to hear from
me of great lies I think she is Jim
first of all I'd like to tell you it's
an honor to hear you speak I've been a
huge fan of your books for years you're
an incredible American history historian
and just a huge source of inspiration
for me I love stand by me one of the
things I was really struck by is that
obviously you're a historian so all of
the stories that you tell in the book
are historically accurate but your
writing is so incredible that many times
I found that it was really emotional and
especially reading the upstairs lounge
reading that event I had to put down the
book and kind of take a minute to
breathe and I was tearing up is it
difficult to write about parts of
history that are so emotionally charged
or can you kind of separate yourself
from the emotions when you're writing
that's a really great question thank you
so much I would say this I mean look
it's the emotional part of the story
that hooks me and writing a book as
anybody knows there's a process it
becomes very academic after a while
there's a process of editing and
rewriting and editing and rewriting that
you you sort of lose that and what I
wanted to do with the book and
especially for the reader is to be able
to part of me is to be able to carry
through that emotion in the same way in
which I found that in the archive and to
be able to articulate it in a way that
was a melodramatic but really tried to
capture the the experience of these
people's lives
back to the New Orleans killing me to
describe he talked about the press
coverage that came in the days that
followed that killing I think it
illustrates sort of like the dynamic of
you know where we were as a people as a
culture I think about this all the time
because we don't know who set the fire
and so a lot of times I say to myself
well maybe it's not homophobic maybe it
was just an act of vandalism maybe it
was an act of violence in general and
then yeah I know I'm tuturro but i but i
second-guessing myself on this all the
time but then when you ask the question
about the press coverage that followed
it one of the questions that the New
Orleans local media asked in the
immediate aftermath of the fire was how
many gay men died and the answer was not
enough or another question was how many
fruit-fly can fit into a jar they were
using that metaphor of a jar as a way of
explaining the bar and people getting
trapped and you know even until this day
you're not going to find homophobia and
such it's in such illustrious of terms
but the way that I've experienced
homophobia as a historian when I tell
this story is people will say well it's
only 32 people there's a way of in the
current moment in 2016 when we were in
that wake of marriage equality when we
think that you know gay rights have been
achieved even today as I talked about
this book and the press covers this book
it's about downplaying it it's about
saying oh it's only 32 people and my
point is not to compare atrocities but
to at least offer a great think about
black civil rights for young girls were
killed in a church bombing in Alabama
that mobilized the movement
thirty two gay men were killed in a fire
that mobilized the movement but due to
the ways in which gay liberation in the
1970s was tenuous it never was able to
accelerate in the same way that gay
rights that black rights were it's
complicated to talk about how the
national media responded to black civil
rights but I would say that for gay
civil rights in the 1970s the story
wasn't even covered and this story was
remains not covered today this story
remains not part of traditional history
books this story remains something that
can be pushed aside or placed under the
headline of gay history not under the
headline of American history
hi you made a really important point
about talking to your questions yeah you
made it really
they give you've been a really important
point about context and how so much of
this forgotten history is rooted in
people's fascination that they're with
counterparts in history
and at the same time so much
androgynous kind of character goes this
far back to a possible tradition the the
relationships and the Iliad and Dionysus
I'm wondering if if there was any sort
of fascination at this particular
juncture in history with with those
kinds of figures in addition to their
American ancestry - well that's a great
question so there's two things first gay
people were trying to find anyone who
looked like them from out throughout
history so they turn to Louie the 14th
they turn to the ancient Greeks and
here's the evidence if you pick up the
Washington Blade today the main
newspaper in DC you're not gonna find an
article about the past if you pick up
the Washington Blade from the 1970s you
will find an article about the ancient
Greece you will find an article about
people living in the Middle East and
they have a kind of orientalist
understanding of sex relations in the
Middle East and in Asia they were
looking for any context to situate their
own experience and more to the point and
this is what I bring up in the book if I
ask any of you in this room where gay
people subject to Nazism you would all
know that's true you would know that
that that gay people are placed in camps
that gay people will exterminate it just
like other groups were during World War
two and my question for you is how do
you know that you know that because gay
men coming out of bars coming out of
community centers went to Berlin in the
1970s funded by gay newspapers in order
to do the research in order to prove
that the genocide of people who were
killed during World War two were not
only Jews but also where gay men because
the traditional chroniclers of that
history did not mention that gay people
are exterminated
and gave people in the 1970s uncovered
this fascinating story about a gay
culture that existed in Berlin in the
1930s and they didn't publish it in an
academic book they didn't publish it in
a professional meeting they published it
in gay newspapers so if you were gonna
come home late at night from a bar you
had a trick you had fun you woke up the
next morning you pick up the gay
newspaper you want to figure out what
happened the next day you would be
reading about the Nazi genocide of
homosexuals and that happened from
community-based historians and so they
didn't see that they were American and
thusly separate from the Germans they
saw themselves as connected to those
people are Jimmy why the title I
understand
so the title initially was called more
than just sex the forgotten history of
gay liberation because I was trying to
explain the ways in which gay people's
lives existed beyond the narrative of
this incredible sexual culture that
rationalize AIDS and then my publisher
said no dice people won't get it people
won't understand it and I thought about
stand by me because it's this incredibly
evocative moment that reminds me of the
church fire that they were singing
united we stand divided we fall if our
back should ever go up against the wall
we'll be together and so the community
the notion of community and culture is
about standing together when Sam Smith
won his Oscar recently he said I am so
proud to stand together with other gay
people so standing together is a
metaphor just like coming out of the
closet a metaphor and so so much of the
book is about stand by me stand by me as
a community stand by me as a culture
stand by me together
[Music]
we probably have time for maybe one more
question
Thanks
[Applause]
[Applause]
book TV is on Facebook like us to get